I would describe the reservation... I'd say
it's really beautiful.
Quiet. Peaceful.
There's no casinos nothing like that. W e pretty much know everybody who lives there
My brothers and I were always close growing up.
As my brother and sister chose UCLA I wanted to be a part of that community
Nobody in my family ever really went to college that I knew, it wasn't like a THING.
My grandmother first went to school because she was forced to go to school
Historical trauma I see that within my
own family.
You know they wanted to please their dad, they wanted to please me. They saw the fruits of their labor.
So always from a young age I knew that I was gonna go to college.
I didn't really know what it was. I just knew it was more school.
We all came at different times so I was here for two years by myself
and then my sister came in
and then Daniel came in you know
My brothers and I were always close growing up.
I think I might had to do with the fact
that we shared a room for like ten years
We did everything together.
You know yeah
they're my best friends.
I don't know what they're doing
I'm not handy like that.
I like to bake or bead. David built me a
loom like... it's like this big and it's adjustable.
So it can go all the way
So I'm just beading sash.
Class of 2018.
Oh that's Daniel's high school graduation
cap.
I beaded this for him.
I think I was a sophomore.
This is David's. Daniel's from high school and David from college
And it's always during finals week they give me this stuff.
My first year here at UCLA was it was really fun just like getting to know the campus and like
taking college classes and meeting new
people. Yeah at times I felt really
overwhelmed I get really homesick David
would take me home a lot.
He had already experienced years of college so he could
you know tell me a little bit like
how to navigate it.
We're gonna imagine that
were like our own like tribe here okay?
and we're determining whether or not
we're gonna have a casino okay
So you are proponents for casino...
I struggled a lot for like two years
It was really hard for me to just pass my
classes you know and learn how to write
learn all these different things that
like I had to relearn all this stuff so
a lot of my professors a lot of the
faculty have really helped me because I
could have just been left behind and I
would've just you know can drop to the wayside
When you have a sibling here or
have your family here it's it's a lot
more comforting like you have
individuals that are always there and
you can always talk to. It's fun to
hang out with them
they were essentially the only role
model I had that were geared towards
higher education. I saw them how they
treated their teachers.
How they respected their teachers, how they respected their schoolwork.
Certain things like that like the way you treat others really plays into your success
Working with kids they all have their
own view of the world and
college isn't necessarily in that view.
I think that's just part of being kids having that innocence.
Whenever I sit down with
a student I try to make sure they
understand why they're doing it with why
it's important.
Mission, huh?
These are actually tough projects.
Having that explanation really helps a child grow
just being around them... they would lift
people's spirits
they'd make them strive harder and it
wasn't because they were you know trying
to put on the show or anything like that
they just had it in them to live like that.
All my shirts are from UCLA. Free t-shirts.
From the powwows the youth conferences
whatever they got going on there
Okay I'm just gonna call the guys up
Jim!
Yo
It's ready.
Okay.
That's something we've always done too.
I just wanted them to have the things that
they needed to have to be able to
survive here. That's my greatest
heartbreak is not finishing my education.
I had a family altercation and I was
sent off of the reservation.
I had to leave the reservation when I was 14 years old and had to leave my school and
nobody really came and got me and said
oh you need to come back you know you
need to finish your school they just
kind of said okay well see you later.
Traditionally we're cremators so
people would pass we would burn.
Burn the bodies burn the possession but we just burn to burn you know because it's
it's it's convenient we don't have like
a dump to take it to or anything like that so.
In a sense too were a developing
community. We've, you know... in the year 2000,
we barely got electricity and
telephones and then running water.
When I was born we didn't have electricity we had a little generator up here.
The house is pretty old now though. Huge
parties here all the time with everybody
from around the rez all of our family
from my dad's side it was always a really good time.
Built this bed frame right here. It's
like in high school...
That's like we didn't have a lot of hard sciences and things like that but I was able to take
small engines, welding like wood shop so that's things that we did do.
Honestly our youth really isn't college bound. I didn't even think that you could  apply to UCLA.
You know that's not a college you can apply to.
I've always believed that you gotta
be a multi-millionaires kid or an actor
from Hollywood to get in there. When
David got in there I was like,
"What?! Holy crap dude."
We come from a background where
we're stereotyped sometimes and and oh
you know what they're Native Americans
so you know they're probably... can't
be educated properly or whatever
the case may be. When you have a family
like the Streamers they've come out and
proven that
hey you know what if we can do it anybody else can do it.
You have the world at the end of your fingers you know you just gotta pull it in.
Basically I always tell people we're survivors if you
can live here on this reservation and be
happy, have a vehicle, have a job...
you're surviving. Cause if not, you're stuck if
you can change things for the better
it's really like a little piece of
heaven
The mountains, the fresh air,
you hear the bees in the rosemary.
This is my people's land so why would I want to leave it.
I want to do a community garden
Every since I was born there's been a garden at our house.
I want to make a better space in this is community right here.
We got tons of
little cousins coming up, growing up.
They're gonna need all the help that they
can get so...
The days get longer and the days get
warmer then they just really start
pumping the eggs out
They're nice.
So my dad,  he's he
made us do our chores, made sure we
weren't fighting with each other
he's always strict with us but he was
never mean to us.
The most important thing, I feel,
they grow up to be honest and
hard-working and to love their neighbors
and that was my greatest desire.
the good
thing about my parents is they never
forced us to do anything you know like
Even though my mom she did she took a lot
of steps to ensure that we were going in
the direction of college you know she
never sat there and said "oh you have to go to college"
Aunt Davida and Uncle Jim they had
presence. They were always there for them.
Always. You know if like when we would
come home sometimes our mom wasn't home
you know we'd come home and then P.J.
would cook us dinner or Toby would make
us whatever we find. Knowing there was
gonna be a meal on the table.
If I leave my mom's still gonna be there when I
come home at the end of the day.
That's a lot for them, you know that
security
I wasn't gonna let my kids be
treated the way I was treated. It just
seemed like nobody cared
There's me. There's Daniel brand-new born. Right at home.
You know, we had we had the best life growing up.
You know, she made sure
that we had a stable household and yeah
so she was just really supportive and just there for us. She was there for
every sports game that we had every
event she was just always there for us
and you know we felt that we knew it and
it made a big impact on our lives.
This is my first notepad.
We just like listed all these colleges that
we thought we you know we should
apply to. Well then I started to figure
out what they needed to get into these
colleges. You know did they have the
right requirements were they getting
that at school. And then at the time I
didn't have internet so I would go to
the library and I would look up things
I didn't know about SAT prep. None of those
things are available at the high school. Nothing.
and then I'm like started
figuring out how to pay for this stuff
My grandmother first went to school
because she was forced to go to school.
Cut your hair don't speak your language
get beat if you act like a savage.
In the late 19th century the United States
instituted a federal boarding school
program for American Indian people. They
had high mortality rates, high levels of disease...
And people were forbidden to
speak their own traditional language or
to enact any of their cultural
traditions. According to the man who
founded the reservation system his plan
was to quote "Kill the Indian and save the man."
There are still people alive
today who remember being taken.
Remember running away from schools.
School really
was a taboo like
"Okay you're going to school because you want to be a white man."
It's not a necessarily an anti-education culture
it's an
anti-government culture
We weren't taught normal history like what happened to the Indians.
so between 1846 and 1873 California's
indigenous population plummeted from
perhaps 150,000 people to just 30,000
survivors. The state government began to
build a state-sponsored killing machine
and the United States Army added to the
death toll. Between 9,400 and 16,000 California Indian people, at an absolute minimum,
were killed.
There's this thing...
it's called historical trauma or
intergenerational trauma. It talks about
how the experiences that happened to
Native people could pass down to
generations generation that's why you
see these reoccurrences of things like
Alcoholism, abuse... all these
different types of things in our communities.
is affiliated with the reservation the
Anybody will attest that is affiliated with the reservation that either
uncle's or aunts, cousins a lot of
them suffer alcoholism problems and
we've lost quite a few relatives because
of that.
And it takes individuals like my mother to break these cycles.
How can you not love them you know? How can you not
love your kids. That's really what all
this is about is about how much I love my kids.
And I went through a lot just to
make a stable home for them you know so they
come home from school because I
would come home from school on the bus
and you know I wouldn't know if my mom
and dad would be there or if they would be drunk or
or, if she would be okay because she
was ill a lot
I just love them so much
and I just want the best for them I want
the best
it seems like there's always a lot of
pushback when I say that I'm gonna try
and go in to law. You can really make
positive change within not only like
large legal structures but also
in your own communities...
Having a good understanding of law makes you become
a stronger leader in American Indian
communities. I still want to be a lawyer to have this knowledge but currently I kind of
want to after these four years I
want to go back home. Wherever I'm needed
I want to serve you know. If I see that
students need an extra tutor I would
step in as that tutor. And like when my
siblings get established in what they
have I would feel more comfortable
going back to school. I think it's very
important that if one of us are there, it'll
better all of us.
One thing I'm really passionate about is the native youth. Sometimes they're just in a bad situation
then I just want to help them get out of that.
I just hope that we can uplift the
spirits of our people. Get things
going. Utilize our resources, we could
really do something but we just have to
physically be there. Definitely this whole
valley, this whole region. I'll
definitely die here.
All native people have their creation stories you know, and their creation stories are where
they come from and for us this is where we come from. A lot of people don't realize that
they're occupying spaces of
that aren't where they're from and
they're trying to make it their own you
know, but this place is really ours.
This is where we're from.